uh we've just got the latest inflation
figures
for you they are now uh up to 4.2
percent
uh in the 12 months to october 2021
consumer price index cpr rose by 4.2
percent in the 12 months to october 21
um up from uh 3.1 percent in september
the trade secretary international trade
secretary anne marie trevelyan is here
um i suppose that means that uh public
sector workers will have to get at least
four percent just to stand still with a
pay rise so i know that the uh
chancellor spoke about this in his
budget and uh the figures looking
forwards identify that there would be a
slight increase
in
inflation in the months ahead because of
a number of the pressures that have come
through as the economies have all kicked
off again post covered and he uh noted
at the time
that department's settlements would be
there so that they could at at a
departmental level have those
conversations with their workforces and
that i'm sure will happen in the months
ahead and the independent review bodies
will be able to uh work with their
departmental uh teams to put forward the
right proposition i mean i've said to
your colleagues in the past i'm not very
good at maths but i mean even i can
figure out that it needs to be at least
four percent just to stand still so
indeed that's what the pair everybody's
there for to work uh with their own uh
cohort of public sector workers and work
with the departmental teams to get the
right so i'm sure we'll see that coming
through in the months ahead okay talk to
me about liverpool if you would we were
all shocked about um what happened we've
heard from the home secretary overnight
um she says
that what happened in liverpool is the
result of a dysfunctional asylum system
is that what you think
so what we saw was was appalling uh
thank goodness that uh the driver of the
taxi wasn't wasn't more hurt and i think
we're all very grateful need for his
bravery and his quick uh thinking uh and
uh hopefully he will be fully recovered
at least from his physical injuries soon
i think uh what we see in the home
secretary obviously has spoken about it
and i'm sure we'll continue to as more
uh evidence as this is looked at comes
through is the challenge of ensuring
that those uh who are asylum seekers who
come to a country because they need our
support our care and the opportunity to
live a safe life in the uk uh should get
here in a safe way so the huge amount of
work that she's doing to stop uh gangs
uh moving people around and abu abusing
their vulnerability is something that
she's very focused on fighting so that
we can make sure that as the kind and
welcoming country that we always have
been and continue to be
we make sure that those who really need
our care and want to be play their full
part in uk society are the ones that
come to the uk and receive our support
but do you believe what happened in
liverpool is the result of a
dysfunctional asylum system
so as the home secretary has already
discussed and she said it herself that
you know in the past this system hasn't
been working and she's been working
incredibly hard in the last couple of
years to really shake that down and make
sure that it is coherent works you know
works well and effectively really
importantly so that those uh who are
genuine asylum seekers and indeed who
want to play a full and positive part in
our communities in the uk across the uk
uh are the people that are coming here
that we provide that support so you're
agreeing with the home secretary with
the home secretary so i think her her
point is uh well may that see what your
opinion is well so my opinion is that i
want to see a system that works uh that
makes sure that those who are most
vulnerable and indeed who uh want to
come here and be a part a fully
functioning part of our uk wonderful uk
uh society are able to get here safely
uh not uh being abused by uh those gangs
who are uh taking advantage of their of
their vulnerability so that's that's
what we want to make sure yeah i'm
talking particularly so i'm i'm uh
obviously not uh cited on the detail of
the case and where the home sector is
but i trust that her judgment uh of that
situation uh and the time frame in which
uh the bomber in question came to the uk
is one at a time when the system uh
didn't work as effectively as it is now
under her leadership are you taking her
word for it that the attack in liverpool
um was um directly connected to the
asylum system in the uk
so as i say i don't know the detail of
the case but you're taking her i think
her point that the system historically
had been dysfunctional and wasn't uh
assessing uh in as uh with as much uh
care as it needed to and to make sure as
i say that those who are uh coming here
and getting us our support through our
assignment system are those who are the
most vulnerable and who want to be a
full part of our uk society when they
get here yeah that would suggest that
the the whole case in liverpool has been
um
investigated and that's the end of it
because otherwise why would she why
would she say that well as the
homosexual she has a great deal more
information at her fingertips and indeed
more widely about the depth of the
system than
those of us who aren't working in the
home office yeah what we need to be
concerned about though is demonizing all
asylum seekers as potential terrorists
well precisely the opposite to that and
that's her point which is
that for those who come here
who we are able to provide asylum for
and who wish to play a full
part in our society of those that we
want to see and we want to support them
and we have some great systems certainly
uh in
northumberland in my patch we have
taken in a large number of syrian
families over the last few years and
they are wonderful wonderful part of our
community now
and you know their children are now uh
thoroughly part of the school system and
very much uh you know northumbrians
adoptees and i think that's the sort of
that's continued to be what uh the home
secretary and the prime minister's focus
is to make sure that that support is
there for those uh families and
individuals who are genuine asylum
seekers back to liverpool though if i
may um as far as the mayor of liverpool
is concerned we had him on the program
yesterday he says the city won't be
divided there's a lot of nastiness
online he said that's trying hatred on
social media as he put it how does the
home secretary's words about um what
happened in liverpool uh being as a
direct result of the dysfunctional
asylum system help to unite the people
of liverpool this morning so i couldn't
believe i think some of the uh poison
that uh social media can create uh is um
beyond unhelpful and can trigger all
sorts of bad behavior and it's great to
see
the voice of liverpool as we would
expect speaking as one saying uh this
was a traumatic and appalling event but
uh the town and all its communities will
stand together against violence
and i think that's where but the home
sector has worked very clearly about the
historic nature of the system and that
now uh
she and her team have been working very
hard to make sure that it works better
and fighting against those gangs who are
trying to abuse the vulnerability of
asylum seekers and their communities
trying to reach a safe harbor okay so
historic um system nature of the system
but i mean you guys have been in power
for 11 years
so as i say the home secretary's been
imposed uh for a couple of years i
suppose
and her work has been very has been very
focused on that well as i say i don't uh
i wasn't involved in that and i think
this is a continuing challenge one of
the really big challenges and we see it
obviously some of the gangs abusing uh
the system as uh they put vulnerable
people into small boats trying to cross
the channel amongst other places and
we've seen it over the years
across the mediterranean those most
vulnerable families and indeed young
people who are seeking a safe life
somewhere safe
across across european countries or
indeed in the uk we need to make sure
that
as the uk we want to bring in those who
are genuinely vulnerable and need that
support and can be full part of of our
wonderful
uk's
communities wherever
they end up making their home here so i
think that continues to be the focus and
that she is driving towards a system
which can ensure that we have uh control
of our borders uh so that we can make
those decisions uh in a rational and
compassionate way nevertheless how can
you be critical of the historic nature
of the system which is letting in
potential terrorists in the words of the
uh home secretary when you guys have
been in power for 11 years as i said so
whose fault is it
so the home secretary uh sits in the
home office and looks after that and
when she came into post she was
determined to make sure that those uh
criminal gangs who were abusing the
system
were they considered so i think
government not doing that before so
that's continued to be a developed case
i think as we've seen some appalling uh
you know very very uh big migration
movements because of war in a number of
countries uh the movements have changed
and indeed these criminal gangs who are
abusing the vulnerability of those have
moved and changed and like all criminal
gangs whatever it is that they're up to
uh it's always a bit of a game of cat
and mouse and i think the home secretary
has been very very robust and she came
into position
who are you criticizing for the historic
nature of the system then whose fault is
it
so the system is is complex like so many
government systems and i think the home
secretary's folks when she came to post
was to make it uh as streamlined as
impactful as possible because she has
always been very clear that one of the
so javid wasn't up to the job well i
don't think i'm sure he did a very good
job but i think when the home secretary
president homes actually came in uh and
because we have seen this huge rise in
criminal gangs abusing the vulnerability
of those uh who are seeking safe harbor
that she has thrown the full weight
of her focus behind that to make sure
that we are able to give
safe harbor to those who most need it uh
many other countries obviously do the
same
and that that is our focus
is that what you're saying so he was
working but i think i think that i think
the point that the home secretary has
made is that the system has has had to
become more robust as the gangs have uh
used migration in a much more uh
aggressive way for their own financial
gain and that that has had to be a much
greater focus and that the present home
secretary has spent a lot of time
pushing it forward
well i think we've seen big increases in
it in the last few years as a result of
these uh terrible and devastating
impacts of war across the world indeed
so not least afghanistan and we saw what
happened there in august talk to me
about sleaze why have we seen a u-turn
from the pm on second jobs
so i was really pleased to see uh the
pm's letter yesterday which sets out two
of the key issues which were raised in a
2018 report putting out a whole series
of propositions i think the pm's
point is well made that i mean these
this is obviously run by the commission
it's not it's not uh determined by
government
but his suggestion that the question of
uh jobs that relate to uh political
consultancy so explaining to
those uh you know a business uh how
parliament works or indeed how uh how
the machinery works is something that is
not appropriate whilst you're a serving
mp okay and indeed that uh the main
focus of your of your time spent should
be focusing on your work as an mp uh and
clearly you know you might be chris
brown you might be a brilliant author
you might in your spare time write books
uh you might be maria caulfield an
amazing nurse who does shifts at the
weekend in her local hospital and so on
but that actually if it's uh related to
your skill set that's fine but if you're
taking your time away from brilliant
access got it that's the broad brush
i've got several supplementaries let's
fire through them what is reasonable
limits on second jobs which is the prime
minister's wording what is a reasonable
limit is that the reasonable number of
hours or a reasonable amount of money
that you're earning
so i certainly don't think it relates to
cash because that's uh that's not a
relevant metric depends what you do like
all of us there's you know you do jobs
for different reasons i think it's going
to be about uh the focus of your uh you
know jc effort you know uh
neither you or i and i work a 40-hour
week in the jobs that we do uh but we
know when we've uh you know decided that
we've had an invitation i think the
point and that came from the commission
which is uh the question about
reasonableness is one that would you
know that the next question will be how
do we how do we assess that and i think
reasonable is something that's
understood so uh you know the chris
bryant author in his spare time i've got
several supplements let's rush through
them uh because of course the vote is
today so other mps will want to know who
decides which second job is appropriate
well so again what what the premises set
out and this was in the commission uh
report back in 2018 uh is to identify
that if it's something to do with uh
your work as an npc explaining as a
political officer who's going to make
that decision well so i think i think
the uh conversation which we'll discuss
will be whether that sits with the
standards commissioner
or indeed a you know a wide court the
the committee i mean that will be a
discussion for parliamentarians to have
i think what we want is someone uh you
know who is able to apply you know a
rational filter so potentially catherine
stone um will there be an appeal process
if you if she says something she says no
absolutely not that's not counted um who
will you appeal to should there be an
appeal process because as we know there
was a bit of an issue with appeals yes
well that i think that's exactly to your
point that's a really important question
which i have no doubt many colleagues
will bring up uh which is should we be
thinking about having a proper appeal
right
so well
all parliamentarians will put forward
and support uh or indeed not support uh
a proposition that's put forward in due
course the vote stays to is to you know
put this into into the next stage of the
process decided there's an appeal though
who will decide uh who will judge an
appeal
well indeed that would be part of the
that would be uh part of the discussions
that colleagues will want to have with
the committee on standards to make sure
that if we bring one in which and that
as you say is one of the reasons why
there were uh discussions and anxieties
over the own patterson case is uh that
it's something that colleagues have have
confidence in because i think that's
important so at this stage we don't know
what it's actually going to mean as far
as reasonable limits and we don't know
what a second job might mean or not mean
we don't know who's going to be in
charge necessarily and we don't know
who's going to be in charge of the
appeal process if you necessarily want
to appeal against a decision that's made
about your second job and the votes
today
the vote is to uh move forward for the
next stage and this and then the the
standards committee uh uh and the
commissioner will uh go away and bring
forward propositions so this isn't this
isn't uh uh a constant there is no
you'd you'd love us and i wouldn't we
all love an instant and complete
solution uh overnight this is an
opportunity the questions that i just
came up with off the top of my head the
cab on the way
i mean seriously because you like but
that's the point uh this is an
opposition day debate where we will
discuss some of these issues and
colleagues will have an opportunity on
both sides of the house to raise their
concerns and indeed hopefully their
suggestions on what isn't it well
welcome to parliament uh the the
complexity of how our system works never
ceases to amaze all of us opposition day
debates uh will bring the opportunity
for this conversation to be had more
fully and then uh the parliamentary
house systems will be able to come
forward with something uh which we can
continue to move as i think an appeals
process personally i think is one that
we want to think about bringing in i
think that's important we are out of
time but i just want to ask you about
caroline knocks um thoughts for her this
morning
so we have a robust uh system if there
are uh concerns within the conservative
party about that and if caroline
obviously wanted to raise that um
on social media i cannot read out some
of the stuff things that you have to
deal with i'm just not going to read
that out there
but you know that is a direct result of
us standing up to be counted well indeed
and i'm very very glad uh that anyone
stands up to canada if uh this sort of
uh as as she suggests uh behavior goes
on it should always be called out to be
investigated in it though won't you i'm
getting well
i i will leave caroline to uh work with
the party on that but uh we have a
robust system in place and i hope very
much that she will uh be able to uh work
that through with the with the party
machine but more widely this is
something that you know all of us who
are women not only in political life in
all sorts of life have for far too long
had to tolerate uh these sort of casual
sexism uh the wandering hand that is
completely unacceptable and most men are
as horrified as you or i are yeah what
would you have done in that situation i
mean if you'd done that at the time i'd
have probably slapped him um which
arguably isn't a better response either
but it would be it would have been an
instinctive response uh from me i think
caroline would have showed great uh you
know personal restraint if she uh
quietly you know moved away i mean i
don't know about you but i'm gonna have
an age where you sit down at dinner and
a hand would suddenly appear on my knee
you know you're like excuse me gentleman
on my left who i don't know could you
remove your hand from my knee that was
that sort of casual sexism was not
uncommon it is much less common thank
goodness now but we do have much better
and robust systems than any woman uh who
receives
that sort of uh abusive behavior uh from
someone absolutely should feel confident
that she can stand up uh both uh face
them down but also uh have the support
of those around her to make sure that uh
the abuser in question does not do that
it is not acceptable and it's not
acceptable whether it's to a woman or to
a young man who are more vulnerable and
indeed uh you know less able to speak
out and we have much better systems in
place to protect them and i would always
uh call anyone who feels
under that sort of pressure to speak up
and we will all stand by them here here
it's good to talk to you thank you for
joining us thank you